agents it's finally time we've caught up
to the recruiter now we can find out who
they are and what are their motives Gear
Up agents this isn't going to be
[Music]
easy the first time the agents were
introduced to the recruiter it was
during a mission at the Jefferson Trade
Center where he was there to observe
Jack Bonnie and assess whether he was
appropriate as a new recruit for the
hunter program Bonnie the Black Tusk as
well as the recruiter would absolutely
destroy Captain Lewis's true Sons but
despite Bonnie's best efforts he would
eventually be killed by agents who
stormed the compound watching everything
play out the recruiter would allow
himself to be seen but would disappear
shortly after in a cloud of blue smoke
the recruiter wouldn't be heard from
again until the rescue of John yai in
this situation it was just a passing
message through a hostile comms that had
been intercepted where the recruiter
handed Yazi over to a Black Tusk
operative the last known sighting was at
the end of the Mari sing rescue he
didn't play any part in the conflict but
he could be seen standing above watching
as the agents called in the extraction
for Mari the recruiter is working for
Kelvin McManus his job is to find
suitable replacements for the hunter
program so why is he watching the agents
so
closely
following the vickram mik rescue Johnson
informs the agents that Vic's sister
birdie is being held by the recruiter at
Camp White Oak and he urges the agents
to go in with
support agent the recruiter is holding
birdie at Camp White Oak after the
attack on the White House I don't want
you going in there without support
Wall-E we're going to need the server
it's not stable there's been some
interference the range is limited
limited is better than leaving our
agents without their Tech you're right
you're right agent I'll have Wally give
John the server he can get you a ride to
camp white
o agent glad you can make it when you
land leave the server and start a sweep
I'll get the server from Fernanda and
cover you aent Johnson how did you get
to White out so fast what are you
talking about I've been waiting for you
who did you think located birdie oh
right sorry guess I'm just getting a
little paranoid with everything that's
happened recently that's fair
agent as soon as you land head for the
bridge agents push forward into the
compound and were quickly greeted by
automated
[Music]
defenses moving deeper into Camp White
Oak it was clear that the Black Tusk had
taken the threat seriously their troops
were defending large sections of the
facility with seemingly no shortage of
resource to be thrown into the
fight agent something something's wrong
with the network I activated the mobile
shade server stay close I don't know how
much range this thing
has system re
activated unable to access system
reestablish
proximity system offline
agent there's some kind of interference
our comms still work but we're losing
access to the shade Tech what the hell
are you doing what's happening your
agent isn't following orders and is
going to get us all killed what orders
my orders agent head to the
bunker system restored this was a
surprising and somewhat outof character
message from agent Johnson but perhaps
it's the stress of the situation so many
in the agents say nothing in response
and continue with the job at hand
hey can y'all stop shooting I'm trying
to work here we need to get you to
safety oh [__] this isn't a
drill tell them to back the [__] off and
stop shooting birdie who are you talking
to
Manny what the hell is going on we're
here to rescue you rescue me what the
[__] are you talking about Black Tusk
have
you again uh no they don't Nat said
we're working together now your agents
brought me here what birdie who brought
you to Camp White Oak your agent you
know the one that looks like a [__]
park
[Music]
ranger
hey Nat how about you let me go with my
brother and we call it even uhhuh yeah I
fixed your power supply issues and
haven't killed anyone yet so how about
you let me go we leave with the server
and call it
even the agents continue to fight
through the hordes of Black Tusk and
would eventually find themselves closing
in on the
lodge agent Johnson come in agent
Johnson the team on site has lost access
to their Tech God damnn it Johnson where
are
you enemy is
watch so I guess Johnson is an [__]
thanks for the rescue
agent agent clear Camp White Oak for
extraction where's the server Johnson
has it oh that makes sense what does he
want with the server birdie Nat is
trying to build I'll tell you later this
Channel's not secure they've infiltrated
our coms your comms are their comms keep
up
[Music]
Manny hey so Johnson or uh should I call
you Mr recruiter what are you up to
birdie oh nothing just hijacking your
mortars for the opposition Force figured
with all of Cal's toys it wasn't really
a fair fight hey agent get to the
helipad before this [__] gets away
with the
server do you have it yes net I have the
server but birdie blew my cover facing
heavy opposition time to suit up Mr
recruiter we are so [__] hey Vic how
did you get on this channel I told you
coms with their coms no one ever listens
Vic get off the comms go get a taco or
something it was at this moment when the
agents would learn that it was one of
their own who was at the Helm of the
program that was responsible for the
elimination of so many of their
colleagues but there was no time to
dwell on this now they needed to keep
pushing forward before the recruiter
agent Johnson was able to get away with
the mobile shd
server the agents find themselves once
again locked down by a seemingly
unlimited number of hostiles defending
the lodge but through patience and
stubbornness to admit that this was the
wrong build to be bring into this fight
they would slowly pull the defense apart
and move towards the final
[Music]
Target mat send the Healer for
extraction copy that agent this is it
hit them with everything you've
got system
curtailed weak point points
detected
agent you know you're on the wrong side
of this war right we serve at the
pleasure of the president we work for
Homeland we work for cow it doesn't
matter if Isaac thinks you're on Mission
the minute you allied with Kelo you went
rogue you think I'm evil because I'm a
Hunter we're the only one still on
Mission if an agent steps out of line
we're here to clear
system back
online system
malfunctioning system
restored after a few practice runs
president you can't beat him pleasure of
the president the agents knew exactly
what to do and would rush in to put a
stop to Johnson before he was able to
get away with the mobile shd
server you can't beat him with shade
Tech agent you should listen to birdie I
can help you but I need to take down the
network you can't do that birdie can't
or won't I definitely can I just need to
upload the counter measure then none of
you will have your little
toys again through complete stubb us and
a willing to see this through agents
would eventually figure out the
massively overpowered recruiter attack
pattern and alongside birdy's stripping
of the network they would slowly break
down his armor but over and over again
he would come back breaking any obstacle
birdie would put in place however she
had a backup
plan agent you can't beat him with your
Tech I have a workaround give me a
minute birdie what are you doing don't
worry about it Mr recruiter birdie you
know me huh
I know you're full of [__] and we'll do
anything for the mission damn it birdie
you know what we're up against I do
agent get clear
birdie system
malfunctioning
loser advancing system
restored a you're making a
mistake clever
girl
[__] Cal will be
disappointed Johnson was a special
project of his too bad he was a true
patriot well I suppose I should
congratulate you you took out Cal's
favorite Hunter and recovered your
precious mobile shade server well done
agent is this all just a game to you of
course not but I know when to cut my l
regroup learn from my mistakes and come
back stronger can you say the same Manny
this isn't over of course not oh send my
best to Mari she really is quite the
Spitfire I can see why you fell for her
she is going to be an excellent mother
you two finished yet I want to go home
Tores you're clear for
extraction what did n want with the
server who Natalia Sova who's that
[Applause]
she's can you please stop messing with
me nope you're too easy you know if you
would have come for me first I could
have told you what she wanted with the
server what the hell are you talking
about N I know what she wants with the
servers seriously yeah she wants them
for her Tech could the Black Tusk really
modify the server for their Tech with
the right code anything is possible you
just have to find the right code or the
right coder birdie did you give her the
right code [__] no that is not my area
you need a programmer a hacker someone
who speaks those languages you need a
wall or CLA or Myra and a server she
would need a working
server while we were there to rescue
birdie she wasn't really being held
captive birdie knows what net wants with
the service to be able to use it for the
black tus Tech fortunately coding this
to work for n isn't something that
birdie is able to do because if she
could have she would have it could be
easy to assume that birdie is an [__]
or or not to be trusted like a brother
Vic but there is more to the story
birdie is obviously a driven individual
and as we heard in the Vic rescue she is
the brains of their operation the thing
that drives her is challenge and this is
something that Natalia was able to
provide birdie you seem Restless maybe a
little bored I am bored anything I can
do to help combat the bordom uh a
challenge maintaining the bunkers isn't
challenging enough for you it's not a
challenge Nat it's a job jobs are boring
no matter how cool they are once you
learn how to do everything it starts to
get a little boring what kind of
challenge are you looking for don't
worry nothing illegal well no more
illegal than you and the cabal boys are
used to how may I challenge you birdie
you remember that Sim CLA was working on
I do it sounded like fun with a couple
of mods it could be a real challenge
what kind of mods huh evolve the area of
effect give the dummies live rounds and
see what happens I'll see what I can do
in the meantime I've got schematics i'
like your opinion
on how many people is this supposed to
support as many as
possible so I guess the question is why
is she helping Natalia Bird's thirst for
Challenge and the drive for the
opportunity to fix problems in her areas
of personal interest is what motivates
her the biggest stuff happening in the
background it holds no significance to
her on top of this Natalia knows this
and is manipulating who more gble
side sup bro birdie you okay you look
okay they they didn't hurt you why would
they hurt me because you were their what
the hell birdie Nat held you captive for
6 months Manny sends his civilian Army
to rescue you cuz who the [__] knows
where Kelo is and all you have to say is
Su bro I'm fine your guys got me out of
there Mario made me a fish taco in this
place seems pretty chill so yeah sup bro
I I love you I love you too uh missed
you bunches what have you been up to oh
you know left to die taken in by my
mortal enemies uh left to die taken in
by not so mortal enemies who also hate
my mortal enemies dude so that was an
into you you got to let it go man that's
not she kidnapped you and made me into
her battery [__] yeah about that why
didn't you just set up solar relays on
the hovercrafts cuz I didn't really want
to help them all right right I probably
shouldn't have converted their engines
to Electric then um my bad you're really
okay yeah why wouldn't I be Nat had me
on all kinds of top secret projects
never boring you know what they say
aboard birdie is a dangerous birdie
secret projects oh yeah you ever seen an
underground city set up to wait out a
nuclear winner can can't say I have me
neither but the blueprints look
promising on the other side of Natalia's
manipulation of Birdie we've now ended
up with someone who has more information
around what Natalia has been up to than
ever before including plans to create an
underground city built to outlast a
nuclear winter perhaps they were
planning to use the nuclear football way
back when Ellis was alive this was going
to be their way of ensuring only those
in favor with the new overlords would
survive still this seems a little bit
over the top so maybe this was just a
beckup plan or we're still to hear more
about
this that should do it you're done yeah
we set up solar panels and wind turbines
hooked them up to your relay built a
series of batteries to store the extra
power in case of inclement weather built
a substation to redirect on days with
two good conditions so we don't overload
the system and have three backup
generators just in case one diesel
retrofitted to use the dirty cooking oil
from mari's Taco Shop one Hydro on rainy
days hooked up up to the roof drain
pipes and one people powered that is
just a stationary bike but that's really
only good for making smoothies you want
a smoothie no I'm good margarita oh yes
please you've actually been to their
headquarters oh yeah dozens of times
[__] kep breaking needed someone to get
the AC back up and running they really
should have built them all below ground
above the water table
the pumps to keep the water out have a
tendency to overheat the bunkers how do
you access the bunkers biometric lock do
you have clearance me no I wish always
had to have one of those btsu brats
accompany me btsu brats you know one of
nat Inner Circle Dolores Jack Galviston
bon
bon do you mean Bon schaer yeah I think
so been a while since I've seen him come
to think of it last couple months it's
just been Jack huh how did they get you
into the bunker was it like a hand
scanner or something hand retinal
biorhythm and voice confirmation all
four at the same time not that
sophisticated really but hard to fake if
it's not the person especially the
biorhythm a couple of times Jack got us
locked out for an hour until the system
reset cuz he was too excited about
something and his heart was beating too
fast so the person is the key yeah you
could say that but I don't think anyone
would say it like that except you Manny
you're like the most dad joke NAD person
I've ever met thank you birie dude
that's not a
compliment and this is exactly what I
was talking about manipulation of Birdie
certainly gained Natalia a very helpful
and useful individual but it also
exposed large areas of her organization
to someone who didn't technically work
for her we can see where this is playing
out just this information on its own
shows how valuable B and schaer will be
if he ever wakes up
I'll admit the recruiter being agent
Johnson was just a little bit of a
disappointment to me to start with
mostly because I had picked him as being
the most likely candidate since the very
first Target this season and it only got
more obvious as the rest of the season
played out perhaps I was hoping for a
bit of a curve ball to be thrown out
there but in saying that for him to be
the most obvious choice means that the
story is playing out in the way that it
was meant to in contrast to some of the
other wacky theories I've come up with
and the story archs due to perhaps
unintended outcomes of certain
interactions however there has been some
extra Intel that has been included in
this season that actually shows us the
events that led up to Johnson being
recruited into the position of the
recruiter the coms I'm about to play
lead on from the events that played out
in the extremist mice Comics you
certainly don't need to have read these
to understand what's happening here but
if you wanted the full background to the
story I'll have a link to my coverage of
these in the
description sir we're approaching the
coordinates should be in DC by Nightfall
agents dun and Ward seemed pretty shaken
up by the death of mantis frankly sir I
don't understand what happened back
there I don't know who took the shot or
who would have killed her to keep her
quiet Cindy can I talk to you for a
second sure agent Johnson how can I help
want to talk to you about agent kelo's
Behavior back there right it was awesome
it was Reckless she made a bomb out of
moonshine ha an awesome bomb made out of
moonshine shine she could have
demolished the building but she didn't
and we got odessa's daughter back and we
took out St Alex when when and when how
well do you really know agent Kelo as
well as anyone can know a coworker
that's what she is to you a coworker
yeah what else would she be an agent of
the division of course she's an agent
but she's also just a person and people
make mistakes and agents go Rogue all
the time so what people can change
that's what worries me you sure you're
cut out for
this I don't know if anyone
is well I guess it's good to see that
Cindy has always been crazy but listen
to what Johnson keeps saying about
Kela agent Johnson Secretary please call
me Cal can I do for you Cal I heard
about mantis and your little tiff with a
drone operator about agent Kelo I
wouldn't call it a tiff sir I wanted to
commend you for speaking the truth yes
we recruited you and trained you but we
never really prepared for a situation
like this how could we even begin to
predict something like this would ever
happen we were never supposed to be
activated you were a fail safe on a fail
safe on an insurance policy on a
catastrophe that was never supposed to
happen and as this was never supposed to
happen some people some Bad actors were
allowed in the hen house so to speak
people like a Kelo people like agent
Keener in New York what is this about
Sir Cal please I need your help aent
Johnson your president your country
needs your
help you wanted to talk to me just
wanted to check in and see how you're
holding up I'm okay keeping busy so I
don't lose
myself sometimes it's easier to stay
focused on the task at hand so we can
complete the mission we need surgeons
the Steady Hand who get the job done I
don't know how many people still fit
that description Cal oh I can think of
one you're steady Brian I think you may
be the surgeon I need to finally Exile
this tumor thank you for the vote of
confidence we never should have made her
an agent agent Kelo agent Lao she was in
the right place at the right time she
used her position to press her own
agenda I don't know what she's up to but
she is not interested in the continuity
of government how else do you explain
your Vendetta against kener I can't
explain it but I want to help contain
the damage they could all do if you
really want to help Brian if you're
ready to take back control I've got a
new assignment for you but I need you to
promise me you'll keep an open mind and
not believe everything you've heard
about nataria
sokova like we heard in the final
mission there agent Johnson is all about
getting the mission done Cal is talking
about every other agent that has
betrayed the division but Johnson really
wants to believe Kela was responsible
for doing something wrong [__] he sounds
like Me 2 years ago except without all
the videos Brian is an absolute Boy
Scout and Cal used this unwavering
attitude and loyalty to drive him into
doing whatever was asked of him so he
made the perfect head of a unit that
would be used to control the actions of
certain shd agents who may have strayed
from their
mission let's just replay the message
from Brian Johnson at the beginning of
his fight scene mat send the Healer for
extraction copy that agent this is it
hit them with everything you've
got system
C weak points
detected agent you know you're on the
wrong side of this war right we serve at
the pleasure of the president we work
for Homeland we work for cow it doesn't
matter if Isaac thinks you're on Mission
the minute you allied with Kelo you went
rogue you think I'm evil because I'm a
Hunter we're the only one still on
Mission if an agent steps out of line
we're here to clean up the
M this single interaction has confirmed
so many different things that we've been
talking about over the months and even
years the hunters are agents their job
is to remove agents who have gone off
Mission agent Johnson wasn't necessarily
bad he was just following his
interpretation of the mission in a
different way to us I touched on this a
few times through the Manhunt being
Rogue doesn't necessarily mean the same
thing as it used to regardless of how he
got there Cal could be the next in line
and even if he wasn't he's the most
senior member of leadership that we are
aware of that is still alive on the
other side we know how he got there and
what he's been doing with Natalia in the
Black Tusk but technically we're not
reporting to anyone we're the rebels in
this
situation so where do I think everything
is going from here well we know that
season 3 is going to be back in New York
and given how often her name has been
brought up through this Mission and
season CA was likely to play a prominent
role there have been a ton of
accusations being thrown at her
accusations that people like myself have
been dishing out for years but if I was
a bing man I would say that the only
thing she'll be proven guilty of in the
upcoming season is that she is young and
a little bit
chaotic I think we found out more about
what Natalia has been up to in that one
Mission than the last last couple of
years combined birdie having worked with
us so closely for so long there should
be a lot of new Intel about the black
task coming out I will admit that last
mission was pretty rough until I figured
out what needed to be done also my
stubbornness with sticking to heroic
diffic difficulty certainly didn't help
once completed it was actually much
easier the next few times I hate timers
on missions but the 10 minutes we were
given seemed more than enough of all the
times I died not once was because of the
timer after the final scene where
Natalia is talking over the speakers Did
anyone run out to check the Black Tusk
controlled propaganda broadcasts in the
open world they're pretty cool Natalia
talks about characters from the novels
her brother Felix president Ellis
General Anderson mcmanis her youth how
the black task are here to help Society
rebuild and a whole bunch more that I
haven't heard yet I definitely recommend
having a listen anyway I think this
video has probably gone on long enough
I'm probably going to break some of
these calms down a little further and
discuss where I think the story is
headed but I'll leave that for another
video but before I go how do you now
feel about that agent Brian Johnson
figurine that have sitting on your shelf
thank you very much for watching and
extremist mes extremer
[Music]
[Applause]
remedia